do you feel like relieved that you don't
have to do stand-up every night
in a weird way
i i know it's complicated it's not like
a one-word answer but i have to admit
like there is part of me
it's i would have never stopped if this
didn't happen right
yeah but it was like a sickness kind of
a little bit
there's there's a lot of healthy things
that happened yeah
during the pandemic that i thought was a
good thing in terms of like um
missing comics like i i never thought i
would miss marc maron i miss my
comic friends so i missed tony so i
never thought about like i mean stoney
yeah you miss certain people that you
would never thought you would miss
and and be and i also miss people that i
thought were my frenemies
you know like got you know like people i
can't say them here because i want to
start a war
you know but you know i know you know
but like you know people that like um
i had to pretend to you know be nice to
when deep down inside
i want to destroy their face you know
but then it's like you
you go what was that all about and
does that matter and i just miss them as
human beings yeah i miss that
and um there's something about this is
what i miss the most
doing a set and then having
all my friends go let's go to
greenblatt's
and it's like 1 30 in the morning and
you're just sitting there and then all
of a sudden like
dom um herrera yeah
like one time dom i wear i was with eric
griffin
dalia and some other guy never heard of
them
and don mirrera and daniel tosh stop by
yeah so then they pull up chairs and i
was with a kid no
i was with a kid that emceed for me
from a club in houston he was just there
he had never been to l.a before oh and
this is this night and this is nice to
hang out with me i said yeah yeah
i told him so he's just i remember
sneaking him into clubs and stuff and he
just couldn't believe it and she's
sitting there and all of a sudden all
these people are there at the diner
and we're just talking shop and telling
stories and i could see this kid like go
this is unfucking believable yeah i mean
what a [ __ ] you know
like a life altering because i've had
those when you were a young guy
where you're in a situation you're like
what the [ __ ] situation am i in here
this is amazing
oh my god this is [ __ ] amazing yeah
right and i feel like those things
sometimes yeah me too
you know so it's like you know i miss
all that stuff and
i will get back to it but i you know i'm
not i'm
i'm one of those kind of guys and that
needs
an audience yeah me too i'm having a
hard time yeah you know because i
realized
during the pandemic that what gets me
off about comedy is being in the moment
and being like i never know what's going
to happen like
kind of coming i've never been a
disciplined writer
if that's